oración regional pidieron los países de
la comunidad andina de naciones can que
se reunieron en lima el presidente
anfitrión pedro castillo quien asumió la
presidencia pro-témpore del bloque
instó el retorno de antiguos países
miembros quisiera expresar la
importancia que tendría para la
proyección de la comunidad andina y el
beneficio de sus integrantes
ampliar su alcance
recuperando como miembros plenos a chile
y venezuela y por qué no pensar en una
integración subregional
que en torno a la idea de una patria
andina
alcance a la hermana república de
argentina esta idea fue respaldada por
los presidentes de bolivia ecuador y
colombia quienes con perú conforman la
can chile y venezuela salieron del
bloque en 1976 y 2006 respectivamente
el retorno de caracas podría haberse
favorecido porque todos los países de la
calle con la excepción de ecuador ahora
tienen gobiernos de izquierda en la
reunión adquirieron el compromiso de
avanzar en una consolidación del sistema
andino de integración que busca que
todos los miembros y un desarrollo
económico y social equitativo hablaron
de la voluntad multilateral para la
reactivación económica tras la pandemia
además crearon el grupo de género y
comercio para impulsar programas de
empoderamiento femenino gustavo petro
atrajo todos los focos ya que se estrenó
como mandatario en su primer viaje al
exterior ocasión que aprovechó para
hablar del fracaso de la guerra contra
las drogas esta realidad amerita que de
la comunidad andina convoquemos una
conferencia de países centroamericanos
suramericanos caribeños para discutir
la política de drogas
evaluarla ver objetivamente se conduce a
algún puerto la comunidad andina surgió
en 1969 estuvo integrada originalmente
por bolivia colombia chile ecuador y
perú